notre point de départ est ici au
rond-point d'emmaüs à tours-nord notre
point d'arrivée la faculté de droit aux
deux lions les sites internet estime
notre temps de parcours entre 20 et 25
minutes selon les itinéraires c'est ce
que nous allons voir
et les premiers mètres du parcours se
font sans encombre au fur et à mesure
les barrières orange et blanche des
travaux du tramway font leur apparition
mais le trafic reste plus que fluide
petit contretemps toutefois la déviation
de l'avenue maginot qui nous fait perdre
quelques minutes
arrivé sur la tranchée rien à signaler
le système des ronds points semble bien
fonctionner
plus loin la rue marceau s'apparente à
un long fleuve tranquille pourtant nous
sommes déjà en retard sur les prévisions
internet nous sommes partis depuis 19
minutes et nous ne sommes pas encore sur
la place jean jaurès en somme si la
circulation s'articule bien ce sont les
déviations qui grignotent les minutes et
allonger les temps d'attentes aux feux
rouges du côté des automobilistes
les avis sont donc partagés c'est
débouchant par seconde c'est un petit
peu la galère ça va ça roule bien parce
qu'à cette heure là ya pas beaucoup de
monde eh bien nous voilà arrivés après
34 minutes 33 secondes et 99 centièmes
sont environ 10 minutes de plus que ce
que prévoyaient les sites internet mais
il faut bien avouer que ce matin les
conditions de circulation étaient plutôt
agréable si nous étions partis une heure
plus tard peut être aurions nous dû
affronter quelques obstacles
supplémentaires